[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
journée consacrée à des débats des
élections législatives un débat un
dimanche pardo quatre débats de débats
ce matin deux autres cet après midi sur
internet c'est le deuxième dimanche de
ce type et il y aura encore dimanche
prochain aucune des deux
circonscriptions de franche comté n'est
oublié au programme d'aujourd'hui les
deux circonscriptions du territoire de
belfort la seconde de haute saône ainsi
que la cinquième du doubs france 3
franche comté vous proposez débat en
partenariat avec leicester républicain
et france bleu d'ailleurs à mes côtés
pour animer ce premier débat de la
journée voici la guitoune journaliste de
france bleu belfort
et puis philippe piot de leicester
républicain il est en poste lui à
belfort également interviendra dans
cette deuxième partie d'émission il
interrogera les invités sur le
développement économique
alors nous commençons cette journée
spéciale débat par la première
circonscription du territoire de belfort
une petite carte pour vous la présenter
c'est celle de belfort centre et est
dell est dans cette circonscription se
trouvent aussi les communes de beaucourt
grandvillars et danjoutin
le député sortant c'est damien meslot
républicain il ne se représente pas il a
choisi la mairie de belfort en effet dès
juillet la loi sur le cumul des mandats
interdit de cumuler maires et députés
nous voyons également sur une palette
les résultats du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle marine le pen
est arrivé en tête dans cette
circonscription avec plus de 28% des
voix
emmanuel macron deuxième avec 20 %
françois fillon 18,3 jean luc mélenchon
en quatrième position avec un peu moins
de 18 % des voix et benoît hamon et
nicolas dupont aignan à égalité avec 5
5% des suffrages
voici la guitoune je vous laisse le soin
de présenter nos six candidats eh bien
je vais commencer par pas représentés
yanbu car il est le candidat les
républicains il est l'ancienne attachée
parlementaire de damien meslot le député
sortant jan bouckaert est également
conseiller municipal à la ville de
belfort et c'est sa première candidature
au législatif christophe grudler le
candidat investi par la république en
marche il est actuellement conseiller
départemental modem depuis déjà presque
20 ans
et ce n'est pas la première fois qu'il
se présente aux élections législatives
on poursuit ce tour de table avec jean
raphaël sandri du front national
il n'a aucun mandat et il se présente
pour la première fois aux élections
législatives une première également pour
bastien photo il se présente sous
l'étiquette mrc mouvement républicain et
citoyen et l'étiquette parti socialiste
il est actuellement conseiller
départemental conseiller municipal
d'opposition à la ville de belfort il a
été candidat à la présidentielle avant
de renoncer faute de parrainages
suffisants
on retrouve également sur ce plateau
anaïs beltran qui fait son entrée en
politique et elle est investie par la
france insoumise enfin sabine verdant
qu'on connaît sur le territoire de
belfort pour avoir été l la secrétaire
départementale de la cgt
elle n'a aucun mandat et elle se
présente sous l'étiquette parti
communiste et puis donc il y à d'autres
candidats qui se présentent également
sur ses inscriptions
mustapha sit in pour le parti égalité
justice roma lagache et finit plus gros
en candidat divers christiane petit os
représente lutte ouvrière et jonathon
vallar d'hiver alors première partie de
ce débat voici la guitoune je vous
laisse la parole pour commencer à
interviewer nos invités alors on va
commencer par yann bout car le candidat
les républicains on l'a dit c'est la
première fois que vous vous présenter à
une élection
votre suppléant et damien meslot le
député sortant damien meslot dont vous
êtes l'ancienne attachée parlementaire
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu sa
marionnette pas du tout pas du tout je
suis yanbu car j'ai 29 ans je suis
candidat aux élections législatives pour
porter une majorité de droite et du
centre et incarner le renouvellement
dans le territoire de belfort
on vous l'a dit j'ai choisi d'amener ce
clos comme suppléant parce que je
m'inscris dans une continuité du travail
qui est fait depuis 15 ans un travail de
proximité d'écouté et d'intérêts des
terrifortains détail for ten c'est pour
ça que j'ai choisi comme suppléant pour
montrer qu'on s'inscrit dans une
continuité
vous l'avez dit j'ai été assistant
parlementaire je connais les dossiers
les gros dossiers du territoire de
belfort
je connais les associations les communes
et je connais le métier ailleurs vous
dites vous souhaitez poursuivre le
chemin qu'a tracé damien meslot
mais quelqu'un quel candidat vous serez
finalement qu'est-ce qui va différer de
ces huiles vous c'est vous ouvrir lui
c'est lui et moi c'est moi évidemment je
voulais dit j'ai un nom un prénom j'ai
un âge j'ai une façon de faire de la
politique une façon de porter des choses
ma campagne a montré le chemin de
campagne sur un projet sur des
propositions je parle pas des
adversaires comme un certain d'autres et
voilà c'est christophe grudler vous
comme si la le disait vous avez donc
l'investiture de la république en marche
vous êtes également modem vous avez été
élu pour la première fois il y a vingt
ans vous êtes déjà présenter à ces
élections législatives
franchement le renouveau proposé est
affichée par emmanuel macron pour vous
c'est pas vraiment le cas mais côté et
désolé je fis le renouvellement pour le
poste de député et avec l'expérience de
lait local
c'est ce qui va permettre la belle
pirouette c'est ce qui va permettre à
emmanuel macron d'avoir une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et dans cette
circonscription le 11 juin
je suis beaucoup plus jeune que j'avais
à peine 50 ans cinquante ans alors autre
français julien il avait 80 ans
donc voilà donc à 50 ans il ya un bon
renouvellement de la vie politique
déjà la politique mais je suis beaucoup
plus jeune que les gens qui vivent de la
politique qu'il ya autour de cette table
deux attachées parlementaires
il ya un ex-assistant de de christian
proust qui est d'ailleurs dans les
coulisses il ya un petit coup de
ripolinage a derrière vous avez bastien
photo mrc avec proust est derrière vous
avez bout car avec meslot derrière dans
les coulisses sympa dans cette émission
mais derrière lui en tant que super ans
vous avez monsieur sandri du front
national qui assistant parlementaire de
monsieur jalkh député européen connu par
ailleurs pour ses propos négationnistes
donc on est vraiment quand même pas dans
une logique de renouvellement jové clé
que les dames symbolise plus le
renouvellement à la gauche de la gauche
on va laisser la parole à jean des
visages nouveaux on va laisser la parole
justement à jean raphaël sandri wassila
donc effectivement l'attaché
parlementaire de jean françois jalkh
député européen front national qui est
mise en examen en 2015 dans l' enquête
sur le financement du parti et qui dans
un journal journal la croix tient des
propos négationnistes a fait mauvais
genre c'est monsieur n'est jamais tenu
ses propos qui lui sont prêtés y sont
mortes et qui sont sortis évidemment
juste après le premier tour de
l'élection prévue le 1er tour élection
présidentielle comme avait été qualifié
au second tour
il a d'ailleurs entamé un certain nombre
d' attaque en diffamation contre tous
les genres certain nombre de gens
haïssent malveillants notamment qui ont
qui ont relayé ces propos qui sont
évidemment d'une façon une manipulation
je peux je vous demanderai un sucre de
l'air de respecter ne serait-ce que le
principe de la présomption d'innocence
qui est au fondement de notre démocratie
est partie que je pourrais aussi demandé
à son avocat d'ajouter des noms la liste
de ceux qui l'a attaqué en diffamation
qui est écrit est écrit monsieur
cendrier qui s'annonce
et après vous êtes bien assistant
parlementaire donc vous êtes aussi vous
baigner dans la politique vous en vivez
aujourd'hui malheureusement la politique
s'est professionnalisé enfin
malheureusement ou heureusement elle
s'est professionnalisé et c'est
peut-être pas plus mal aussi que les
françaises sont représentées par des
gens qu'ils soient qu'ils soient très
compétent sur les sujets politiques
il faut une certaine diversité je crois
à l'assemblée nationale ce qui inclut
aussi des profils des gens qui sont là
qui connaissent le fonctionnement alors
autres professionnels de la politique
avait l'air de dire christophe butelet
revault fabien photo alors je dis
anglais ma question comme on dit bastien
photo vous sur votre affiche vous
présenter comme de la gauche
républicaine socialistes écologistes
progressiste radical ouf j'ai envie de
dire vous annoncer que jean pierre
chevènement qui vous soutient c'est le
premier des insoumis
quelle belle récupération mais c'est la
réalité il ya une réalité et les factuel
ça se sont pas des interprétations
dès 1991 1992 jean pierre chevènement
quitté le parti socialiste en sur deux
questions centrales la question la
participation de la france à la guerre
du golfe et la question du traité de
maastricht
on voit aujourd'hui dans quelle
situation se trouve le continent
européen et la construction européenne
du fait même des déséquilibres du traité
de maastricht
donc il a été éclaireurs au moins sur
ces dossiers là et donc vous vous
revendiquez
on dit que je suis à ses côtés depuis 17
ans je me suis engagé
dans la vie politique comme simple
militant lorsque j'avais 20 ans à ses
côtés et il est vrai qu il est vrai
catherine que dans le paysage actuel
c'est un peu curieux des gens qui ont
une trajectoire droite parce qu'on a
beaucoup de gens qu'elle croise de
droite à gauche non une trajectoire
droite j'appelle traducteur gauche
républicaine socialistes écologistes
progressent israël dans ce cas rien son
blond l'ensemble de ses composantes
voici la photo quand même écouter quand
on rassemble pas on nous reproche d'être
tout seul
et quand on rassemble on estime que
c'est du fourre tout je pense que la
capacité de rassemblement est un message
important pour les citoyens du
territoire de belfort
on va passer à anaïs beltran qui est la
candidate de la france insoumise jean
pierre chevènement le premier des
insoumis ça vous inspire quoi
oui merci de me permettre de revenir là
dessus je voudrais faire honneur au
dernier article paru dans l'est
républicain
concernant les déclarations de monsieur
chevènement qui soutient dans la 2e
circonscription monsieur kern qui est en
marche et qui soutient bien sûr son
ancien copain christian rayot qui est le
suppléant de monsieur faut donc dans la
première circonscription dont clairement
on voit bien que le rassemblement de
monsieur photos qu'ils proposent c'est
un rassemblement opportuniste d'ailleurs
je me demande pourquoi sur les tracts
qu'il n'y a pas la petite rose du ps
étant donné que son comité de soutien
c'est madame jaber qui fait partie du
parti socialiste et en même temps je
tiens à souligner l'incohérence de
monsieur photos étant donné que il a
quand même négocié sa place dans la
première circonscription avec benoît
hamon qui l'a soutenue pendant les
présidentielles
il est venu me demander de me désister
sur la première circonscription au
lendemain du score de jean luc mélenchon
alors que nous avons un électorat à
respecter donc voilà toutes ces
politiques
bernard à dire que je les rejette
complètement on va finir ce premier tour
de table avec vous cette benne verdon
donc vous représentez ici le parti
communiste donc on a un candidat du mrc
ps de la france insoumise il ya aussi
lutte ouvrière avec christiane petit os
c'est vraiment l'embouteillage à gauche
de la gauche non non je ne pense pas
parce que on peut on peut remarquer
quand même
enfin moi je me mets à la place des
électeurs et des électrices c'est un
vrai cafouillage ces élections entre
france a soumises qui veut remplacer le
ps le ps qui s'associe à aa qui se
revendique de la majorité présidentielle
et christophe kugler de en marche je
pense que les électeurs doivent tête un
peu perdu au milieu et moi je suis
contrairement à ces messieurs je suis
issue je ne suis pas une professionnelle
de la politique mais je suis issu de la
société civile
je suis syndicaliste et me présenter
c'est dans la continuité de ce que j'ai
fait jusqu'à présent
alors voici la guitoune a laissé sa
place à philippe piot qui est le
journaliste de leicester république a à
belfort mesdames messieurs il a choisi
de vous interroger sur le développement
économique et l'emploi dans cette 1re
circonscription du territoire philippe
piot vous avez la parole
merci je suis content de ce débat parce
que cela va permettre sur ces questions
d'un petit peu préciser les choses
j'en étais resté mois à la primaire où à
l'époque yann boucard et christophe
grudler donner leur avis sur la primaire
de droite et du centre aujourd'hui l'un
se retrouvent candidat des républicains
l'autre se retrouvent candidats en
marche quand on lit les programmes qui
étaient ceux portés par françois fillon
qui était supportée par la jupe et qui
étaient ceux portés par emmanuel macron
qu'est ce qui distingue votre approche
en terme d'emploi et d'économie
fondamentalement entre vous deux coups
nature est mou car l'objectif de la
majorité la boîte du centre c'est de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux français
on l'a dit notamment sur les termes
économiques avec une gazelle 1 pouces
revenus de 10% avec une hausse des
petites retraites et des pensions de
réversion pour favoriser justement le
pouvoir d'achat des français
économiquement et notamment sur les
entreprises je pense qu'il faut baisser
considérablement les charges salariales
et qui pèse sur les entreprises pour
remettre
justement nous on paie titille nos
entreprises de manière compétitive on
sait que les français sont parmi les
ouvriers les employés les plus
productifs
aujourd'hui on a un certain nombre de
charges qui pèsent sur leur travail et
qui fait qu'ils sont compétitifs que
leurs voisins
propose pour cela par exemple de baisser
l'impôt sur les sociétés à 25% ce qui
est la moyenne européenne va laisser
répondre sur cette question écoutez
emmanuel macron c'est l'union des
progressistes dont il ya des gens
d'horizons différentes les gens qui
viennent de la droite des gens qui
viennent du centre de la gauche qui
viennent de la société civile qui se
retrouvent et qu'ils veulent donner une
majorité est mal j'ai entendu là
emmanuel macron le propose aussi la
baisse de l'impôt sur les sociétés par
exemple on le retrouve chez l'animal
alors qu'est ce qui distingue l'offre d'
emmanuel macron la politique qui va
mettre ses claviers à une offre plus
globale en fonction de l'origine
politique des uns des autres qui tient à
la fois du respect des salariés du
respect des chefs d'entreprises dont je
suis juste à préciser que je ne suis pas
un professionnel de la politique
donc il ya un respect de tout le monde
dans ce programme économique qui a un
plan de relance et il ya un espoir dans
le pays que le plus qu emmanuel macron
est élu président il faut relancer
l'économie la croissance va être là la
consommation va être là et les choses
seront plus beaucoup plus facile pour
nos prévisions à bastien photo le mrc a
une position lorsque la loi est comme
ries est passé aujourd'hui on revient
sur la loi travail quelle est votre
position sur ce qui est en train d'être
mis en place
parce qu'on a bien compris que vous êtes
soutenus par jean pierre chevènement qui
soutient aussi de l'autre côté un
candidat en marche mais vous êtes
d'accord avec la politique est en train
d'être mis en place deux fois qu'on fait
leur marque mais je propose qu'on
interroge directement jean pierre
chevènement
je ne veux pas le faire parler il ya une
chose qui est certaine aujourd'hui si
vous voulez d'abord la loi y compris les
parlementaires du mrc s'y sont opposés
et ils ont déposé le projet de motion de
censure contre le gouvernement valls sur
ce dossier spécifique
il va de soi que demain je poursuivrai à
l'assemblée nationale la ligne est
l'orientation qui était celle du refus
de l'inversion de la hiérarchie des
normes est ainsi bloquée sur le
circonscrire et on ne va pas commenter
ce qui se passe sur la première
circonscription
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'en fait il
ya un candidat qui soutient un candidat
qui soutient pas alors que jean pierre
chevènement soutient les deux quoi vous
voulez vraiment que c'est une obsession
je sais que c'est un grand pas moi qui
vais vous dire le contraire donc vous
aussi vous êtes à l'assemblée nationale
ses contres d'abord je suis un homme
libre
tout le monde le sait j'insiste sur une
chose j'ai une trajectoire droite vous
interrogez à l'instant vous les deux
interlocuteurs en face de la droite dix
autres
10 ionel même si aujourd'hui elle est
masquée qu'elle se peinturlure derrière
une couleurs centristes un peu
attrape-tout pour la peine du centre des
progressistes quoi en fait
la réalité c'est que vous interrogez ils
ont même programme parce qu'ils sont
d'accord depuis toujours ils ont des
désaccords de personnes comprend que
vous êtes vous êtes content on va
peut-être interrogé donc les deux
représentants il est la gauche de la
gauche anaïs beltran on est sur une
circonscription historiquement
industriels on est aussi sur des
thématiques sociales
vous vous présentez un programme où il
ya beaucoup d'écologie on vous a peu
entendu sur la question industrielle
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez en dire oui
donc notre programme l'avenir en commun
justement c'est la planification
écologique mais l'idée c'est de faire de
l'état un acteur et un stratège au
niveau industriel à travers la
planification écologique on relance
l'activité et l'emploi
hélas alstom par exemple qui a perdu son
sa production dans le fret ferroviaire
se verrait des deux femmes dès demain si
j'étais alstom et dans la première
circonscription pour le sud de le sud du
département des lbo cours qui sont en
difficulté industriellement parce qu
effectivement pour parler d'industrie
ont fait des choses on parle de belfort
mais il ya un sulky et également
industriel dont on ne parle pas qu'est
ce que vous proposez
on revient à la source du problème c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui si on suit les
politiques de en marche ou de la droite
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui compte c'est
les prix les prix les prix la
compétitivité la compétitivité donc nous
nos stratégies c'est la relocalisation
de la production
je rappelle quand même même si je suis
dans la première circonscription on est
entouré de forêt on a aussi une
planification forestière à savoir
développer la filière bois vous
permettez que je vous interromps qu'on
va laisser la parole à l'ats sabine
verdant pour le parti communiste alors
sabine verdant la dernière fois qu'on
s'était vu vous manifestiez contre la
loi m comme rivaux la candidate je pense
que vous n'avez pas changé d'avis qu est
ce que vous pensez de ce qui est en
train d'être mis en place actuellement
moi je suis très inquiète pour les
la classe la classe ouvrière parce que
on est en train enfin mâcon et son
gouvernement de droite est en train de
casser la protection sociale le droit du
travail et ça je ne pense pas que ce
soit bon pour le développement
économique
au contraire quand on parle de charges
sociales ou un ça me fait mal aux
oreilles
ce ne sont pas des charges sociales ce
sont des cotisations sociales réviser un
peu votre histoire vous verrez un
salarié coûte pas il rapporte et ça
c'est intolérable entend des choses
comme ça dans la politique
alors quand les gens disent la politique
pourri non c'est pas la politique qui
est pour hisser les politiciens qui sont
pourris et ça il va falloir y faire
quelque chose aussi parce que la justice
aussi les ouvriers eux ils n'ont pas le
droit à l'erreur
eux ils sont vite moi j'en ai fait aussi
un petit peu l'expérience récemment ils
sont traduits devant la justice pour
défendre leur parce qu'ils défendent
leurs droits par contre certains sont
tranquilles à l'aise dans leurs baskets
un merci madame verdon monsieur landry
alors on a suivi les débats à l'élection
présidentielle quelle est la position du
front national en matière d'industrie on
est dans une zone frontalière alors on
se souvient aussi de ce que nous disait
marine le pen qui voulait remettre des
frontières d'elle travaille beaucoup
avec la suisse on remet des frontières
des échanges jouer de compliqué quel est
votre projet pour ce secteur particulier
à la fois industriel et frontaliers et
on a beaucoup caricaturé le produit
fonctionne évidemment notamment en
matière économique et on a relayé le
franc je ne veux pas fermer les
frontières donc comme ça a été fait le
fonctionnent comme s'était dit le
fonctionnement des frontières tout
simplement et passent d'abord pour une
question économique mais d'abord pour
une question de sécurité et est évident
que aujourd'hui étant donné mais je sais
bien que ce sera notre m mais tout à
l'heure c'est d'abord pour des raisons
de sécurité qu'on veut des verts vous ne
vous n'avez pas la cram de grippe et ce
qui se passe s'il faut mettre deux
heures pour passer la mairie de
travailleurs frontaliers
est-ce que ça va pas nuire à l'économie
puisque nous sommes justement une zone
frontalière les frontaliers qui
travaillent en suisse savent très bien
que la suisse
avec qui n'est pas de l'union européenne
qui a adhéré très récemment espace
schengen auparavant il n'y avait aucune
difficulté pour passer la frontière ça
fait des années passent la frontière
nommé pour les pour laisser pour les
citoyens qui vont travailler il ya aucun
problème il ya aucune raison qu'ils
aient des problèmes des différences à la
frontière entre citoyens et qui va
travailler est quelqu'un qui passe pour
aller en suisse les frontières servent à
protéger et en matière économique
les frontières sont là ce que nous
proposons nous ce qui a été démantelé
c'est une forme de protection c'est à
dire des tarifs douaniers sur les
importations qui font concurrence aux
industries françaises ça ne veut pas ça
ne concerne pas les personnes
les travailleurs qui s'ajuste d un
produit voici la renier ces temps là les
produits qui font concurrence à
l'industrie française très bien donc il
reste donc je regarde sur le chronomètre
un peu plus de huit minutes dans ce
débat voici là vous avez repris votre
place quelle nulle par exemple quelle
est la question que vous voulez
peut-être un peu creusé avec un bouquin
avec jan bouckaert bah écoutez en vous
entendant on a l'impression en fait que
le programme que vous proposez en
économie c'est le même que celui de
monsieur grudler et de la république en
marche la baisse la baisse des charges
de la halle baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés de 33 à 25 finalement c'est la
république en marche il ya évidemment
des points de mire voter plutôt que de
voter par ont voté pour le président de
la france qui a évidemment des points de
convergence entre tous les programmes je
crois que ce qu'il faut choisir aussi
faudra choisir pour cette élection
législative notamment celle de choisir
quelqu'un qui a de la cohérence les
bassins à flot de l'adie justement ce
qui se passe à 1 puis quand marche on
n'y comprend plus rien expliqué très
forte où effectivement que ce togolais
rpt qui a été un ancien du rpr qui est
ensuite délégué général du modem qui a
soutenu alain juppé pendant la primaire
qui a donc signé une charte s'engageant
à soutenir le vainqueur de la primaire
je vous en prie le coller derrière des
jupes évasées ville macron non je note
d'ailleurs je me sens très que 110
native packard est jugé
il était beau ce matin toujours gt1
molina de la droite et du sne et arrange
mais j'ai quand il faut une cohérence
parce qu'effectivement quand on regarde
le monde emmanuel macron on ne sait pas
ce qu on ne sait pas s'il se répondent
christophe grudler alesi non mais je
comprends que quelques ce que ça fâche
un petit peu mais effectivement les
juppéiste sont en grande majorité
l'électorat d'alain juppé se retrouvent
de la dynamique de la macreuse
d'emmanuel macron pardon comme comme de
nombreux progressistes de tous les
horizons
il faut dépasser les vieux partis il
faut dépasser ce côté ringard qui bloque
la france depuis 20 ans maintenant on a
la chance d'avoir des gens qui se
rassemblent qui unissent des compétences
et vous voulez bloquer le pays
en remettant une cohabitation en mettant
les gens mal et que dans cinq ans on
soit au même point qu'aujourd'hui alors
qu'on a une chance historique avec un
président de la république qui fait la
quasi unanimité dans le pays
ce président il est là pour construire
avec tout le monde ne vous placez pas
dans une logique de la venue de
cohabitation d'avoir dès lors des cinq
dernières années j'ai pas l'impression
que le pays aille beaucoup mieux
s'apprécier beaucoup mieux les tests
nous voici là une question pour monsieur
cendres est exactement front national
dont vous avez parlé de sécurité de
frontières alors qu'on vous a posé la
question sur le projet industriel va
poser la question sur les sur les
frontières donc je réponds notre
position sur les frontières est d'abord
lié à une question de sécurité
et quel est votre voix laquelle votre
projet industriel sur le sud territoire
le projet du sommet le premier du seul
sur ce territoire c'est toute la france
qui c'est devenu industralisés c'est
pour des raisons nationales c'est parce
que notamment et on s'est sorti tout le
temps sur les députés demandent un
député n'est pas amer un député siégeant
à l'assemblée nationale un député vote
les lois d'obésité vote notamment la loi
de finances un député est là pour agir
sur la politique voilà seul et déterminé
le gouvernement qui gouvernera le pays
donc nous avons nous donne ce territoire
un réseau de pme pmi qui est totalement
oublié par les politiques économiques
aujourd'hui au niveau national par des
dispositifs comme le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi et qui a été lancée
je crois d'ailleurs par monsieur macron
l'époque où il était conseiller
économique de monsieur longuet qui ne
profite qu'aux groupes du cac 40 on
s'est rendu compte que les pme/pmi n'en
profite et quasiment pas donc
aujourd'hui il faut c'est vrai baisser
les charges il faut c'est vrai baisser
l'impôt sur les sociétés mais le
problème c'est que d'abord on a des
candidats qui dit ça mais qui
appartenaient les familles politiques
qui sont réputés pour n'avoir tenu
aucune de leurs promesses ces dernières
années et ensuite il faut le faire sur
les bonnes entreprises sur les
entreprises qui créent malheur reste 5
minutes dans cette émission donc on va
passer rapidement aux conclusions mais
une dernière question pour vous bastien
photo vous dites je suis un homme libre
ce que je vis toujours été je n'y a pas
de souci en revanche effectivement vous
a pas entendu non plus sur voilà le
projet que vous pourriez avoir pour le
la séquence est ce que vous ne m'avez
pas interrogé sur le sujet sur la
question et calomnies il a trouvé
fectivement et je ne les cache pas que
je suis soutenue par jean pierre
chevènement vous l'avait dit et redit
christian proust christian rayot qui est
mon suppléant qui a mis en oeuvre des
projets des politiques publiques
particulièrement audacieuse volontariste
ambitieux sur le chu territoire on le
voit c'est l'économie mixte à belfort
c'est techn'hom au niveau de la gare tgv
c'est la jonction dans ce territoire
c'est la scène sud avec les sites de
l'isie d'elle l'isi grandvillars vmc et
c'est donc il y a des possibilités
autour des responsables politiques
locaux et de vous interrompre question
si important et oui mais c'est la
démocratie vous êtes si sur le plateau
une dernière question pour vous monsieur
cendres et donc sur l'autre
circonscription les là le roi
la candidate du front national ça vous
dit quelque chose ou pas c'est l'autre
qui la connaissent et territoires
personnellement il avait rencontré non
c'est une c'est une cb cognac apporter à
nos circonscriptions donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi on parle de l'autre
circonscription sur le débat par l'état
on suppose qu'elle ne viendra pas au
débat c'est un vélo pour la vie
personnelle 2e circonscription
donc évitons va faire la conclusion on
va commencer par vous sabine verdant
juste vingt secondes pour conclure ce
débat sur cette circonscription pour
conclure moi je pense que les électeurs
et électrices ont besoin de savoir où
ils vont
on se rend compte qu'il ya des problèmes
au niveau des salaires et des pensions
il faut absolument réévaluer les
salaires et les pensions
c'est pas de faire de l'austérité dont
on a besoin c'est bien de protéger les
salariés et protéger les salariés
protégés aussi évidemment les outils de
travail
quand on parle du cce c'est de l'argent
public qui est donnée à l'aise je suis
désolé d argent à bon prix
gratuitement entreprises sans
contrepartie on est dans des conditions
peu de partage s'il vous plaît merci
vous avez 20 secondes pour lui alors 20
secondes je voulais rappeler à monsieur
grue de l'air que c'est sous la
cohabitation du gouvernement jospin que
l'économie ne s'est jamais aussi bien
portée voilà nous notre objectif c'est
de créer une majorité d'insoumis qui
n'ont rien à voir avec tout toute cette
politique à l'ancienne on veut peser en
fait pour vraiment appliquer notre
programme l'avenir en commun et ordonné
qu'on n'a pas le temps que sur le
plateau je vous incite à aller voir
l'avenir en commun avec universciné
thématique bastien photo 20 secondes
pour terminer on va faire simple puisque
la seconde
emmanuel macron aura une majorité les
cas voir s'ils sont interchangeables
il se bat tous en fête pour le rejoindre
à gauche à droite au centre
moi je prends l'engagement clair je
siégerai dans l'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale conformément à mes convictions
depuis toujours de position qui sera pas
une obstruction une opposition
constructive comme je le fais à la ville
à belfort et au département
mais une opposition sur tous les projets
de régression sociale cias andré pour le
front national votre conclusion s'il
vous plaît je crois qu'il ya un débat
qui était totalement exclue de lors
d'élections présidentielles et qui
aujourd'hui a été également également
occulté alors que comme j'ai rappelé un
député est élu sur des questions
nationales c'est évidemment la menace
islamiste sur notre sur notre pays et
même d'ailleurs sur toute l'europe
on n'a pas parlé on n'a pas parlé des
solutions des différents candidats pour
ses blessés et pour une raison qui est
extrêmement simple c'est que le seul les
français savent bien les seuls qui ont
des solutions pour vaincre l'islamisme
qui peut faire preuve de fermeté face à
la question islamistes si ça très bien
que c'est le front national
christophe sud emportant dans ses
chaussures grudler 20 secondes pour
terminer s'il vous plaît l'objectif de
cette élection législative c'est de
donner une majorité emmanuel macron sur
cette circonscription tout le monde est
contre lui je suis le seul à défendre et
à porter ses couleurs
j'apporte mon expérience mes compétences
mon réseau parce que je connais
personnellement plusieurs ministres je
pense que ça peut être utile pour le les
habitants de la circonscription et
j'appelle j'amène également un travail
d'homme de terrain donc habitants de la
première séquence rivaux du territoire
de belfort
mobilisez vous dès le dimanche
11 juin pour faire gagner les idées de
menus et de macron en marche pour la
france et les français est à nouveau car
votre conclusion s'il vous plaît moi
j'appelle les habitants du territoire de
belfort à choisir un député qui leur
sera utile qui aura comme seule boussole
à l'assemblée nationale les intérêts du
territoire de belfort et de la frange
m'inscrire et ni dans une opposition
systématique dans une majorité docile
que monsieur grue de l'air et je
voudrais juste mettre en garde contre le
front national le front national n'a pas
de solution parce que c'est des
problèmes des français que vient leur
fonds de commerce
je choisis c'est un député utile merci
mesdames merci messieurs je rappelle
qu'il ya d'autres candidats dont qui se
présentent sur cette circonscription
mustapha sitting du parti égalité
justice roma lagache et philippe legre
ou divers christiane petit ou pour lutte
ouvrière et jonathan vallar en divers
merci de votre participation mesdames
messieurs merci wassila où l'on retrouve
cet après midi pour le débat de la
deuxième circonscription du territoire
de belfort et je demande aux autres
invités de venir prendre place pour le
deuxième débat de cette matinée à savoir
donc la deuxième pardon la deuxième
circonscription du territoire de belfort
voilà on va jouer le direct venez vous
asseoir mesdames et messieurs c'est vous
s'il vous plaît et donc c'est la
deuxième circonscription de haute saône
doxi et les invités du premier débat
veulent se disputer vont se disputer
dans le couloir merci beaucoup donc
celle de l'ouest de la haute saône où se
trouvent les villes de luxeuil lure et
héricourt
le député sortant c'est le socialiste
jean michel villaumé ps il a choisi de
ne pas se représenter après deux débats
et puis à noter que les limites de cette
circonscription date de 2012
les deux anciennes circonscriptions la
deuxième et la troisième ont été
remaniées il y a cinq ans je vous donne
aussi les résultats du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle qui a eu lieu
je vous le rappelle le 23 avril dernier
marine le pen est arrivé en tête avec
32,9 pour cent des voix elle a réalisé
ici le score le plus haut de toutes les
circonscriptions de franche comté
emmanuel macron 18,9 en deuxième
position jean luc mélenchon et françois
fillon en troisième et quatrième avec
16,6 et 16,4 et nicolas dupont aignan et
benoît hamon avec 5 5 et 5 % alors donc
dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission
nous recevrons également nicolas basse
tuque qui est le journaliste de l'est
républicain qui interrogera nos invités
justement sur le score élevé de cette
circonscription pour le front national
et puis à mes côtés le journaliste de
france bleu qui va animer ce débat
il s'agit de jean françois fernandez qui
est en poste à vesoul l'homme merci
d'être ici jean-françois donc
jean-françois vous nous présenter les
six candidats présents sur le plateau
alors on va commencer par isabelle g 1
pour la droite et le centre alors vous
avez 50 ans vous êtes directrice
d'associations qui gère des maisons de
services aux publics en milieu rural
vous habitez un mail c'est près de
villersexel et vous n'avez pour
l'instant aucun mandat
christophe le jeune christophe lejeune
pour la république en marche vous avez
48 ans vous êtes assureurs et courtiers
en crédit vous habitez à luxeuil
vous êtes maire depuis 2008 de bodo
courez vous étiez présenté au
départemental en 2015
maurice monnier candidat du front
national 34 ans vous êtes contrôleur des
douanes vous habitez à chaud la halle
aux tiers vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du front national dans le
département de la haute saône depuis
deux ans et vous étiez également vous
aussi présenté au départementale quand
un arbre cost vous êtes pour le parti
communiste vous êtes le plus jeunes
autour de cette table aujourd'hui 30 ans
magasinier de profession vous habitez à
héricourt débitait vous êtes originaire
de vous non alors vous n'avez aucun
mandat politique en revanche vous êtes
élu dans votre entreprise au cee et vous
est également membre du conseil
citoyen d'héricourt patrick adam pour
debout la france 47 ans médecin
psychiatre
alors vous habitez à cendres cours près
de jussey vous n'avez aucun mandat mais
vous intervenez beaucoup par
l'intermédaire de votre profession
notamment dans le milieu agricole et
vous est également expert aux tribunaux
et puis on termine par isabelle esman
fait levé 45 ans vous êtes mariée mère
de trois enfants vous êtes candidate
pour la france a soumis ce bien sûr
secrétaire administrative dans une
maison d'accueil spécialisée vous
habitez à froid de terre et vous n'avez
pas de mandat mais vous êtes beaucoup
impliqué dans la vie associative
alors sept autres candidats sont en lice
dans cette circonscription de haute
saône christophe devillers le parti de
la france
mario gaza alliance écologiste
indépendante fatigue du wincq parti
égalité justice comme marc onno sans
étiquette
evans petitjean upr daniel rouillon
lutte ouvrière et marie claire thomas
d'europe écologie les verts jean
françois je vous laisse poser la
première question
alors isabelle g 1 il appelle par dont
il avait
tandis 12,6 mélanger c'est isabelle
esman pardon avec qui vous devez
commencer ce débat un petit mélange vous
avez fait un petit mélange donc c'est
moi qui vais poser cette première
question le temps que vous retrouviez
dans la note jean-françois oui et
françois fillon arrive seulement
quatrièmes dans cette circonscription
avec 16%
vous partez de loin pas vraiment de loin
iem 16% s'est pas beaucoup comparent pas
vraiment de loin non non non vous le
voyez bien là on est sur la droite et le
centre
depuis le début mois ça fait plusieurs
mois que je suis en campagne sur le
terrain l'union et à droite et le centre
a été faite entre les airs et puis lui
dei depuis des mois l'union excusez-moi
de vous interrompre stéphane cros maire
avait bien envie d'y aller quand même
l'approché de l'investiture j'ai vu les
investitures en juin 2016 qui m'a été
confirmé une nouvelle fois en janvier
2010 c'est entre nous et parce qu'il
fallait une femme extrêmement clair elle
est une femme
absolument pas non non non non c'est
parce qu'eux aussi avaient besoin de
compétences il y avait besoin aussi de
sang neuf
je suis au quotidien je suis directrice
d'associations qui oeuvrent en milieu
rural je rencontre au quotidien des
personnes des agriculteurs des chefs
d'entreprise des personnes qui sont
recherche d'emploi vous allez servir et
que vous êtes là j oui mais c'est pas
seulement parce que l ai roulé mais tout
à fait et donc je suis toujours à
l'écouté et c'est bien ça qui a après
qui me permet de m'engager en politique
et la commission nationale d'investiture
a bien reconnu mes compétences
j'étais d'ailleurs renommé à plusieurs
reprises experte au niveau du préfet et
donc c'est aussi pour ça voilà
christophe lejeune donc vous vous
représenter le parti de la république
remarche d' emmanuel macron vous êtes de
gauche vous sortez du chapeau là parce
qu'on vous voit arriver comme ça qu'est
ce qui justifie cette investiture
cette investiture elle est tout
simplement justifié par la commission
nationale d'investiture de la république
en marche
j'ai été choisi au milieu c'est arrivé
paris vous avez été choisi de paris tout
à fait j'ai rejoint emmanuel maupas et
passez pas venue du terrain
non puisque c'est un mouvement neuf donc
le terrain
encore structurée et des règles du jeu
ont été définis c'était paris qui allait
décider pour chaque circonscription des
règles du jeu ont été posées clairement
accepté par tous les candidats et je
m'en félicite maurice monnier vous êtes
apparu dans le département il y a deux
ans en ouvrant notamment une permanence
à vesoul vous aviez dit en arrivant que
vous vouliez vraiment changer un petit
peu l'implication du du front national
dans le département sur cette
circonscription plus de 50% aux
présidentielles au delà de surfer sur le
score du front national qu'est ce que
vous proposez à tous ces électeurs qui
refusent aussi bien le candidat sortant
de gauche que les candidats de droite
on propose tout simplement un renouveau
politique que les haut saônois attendent
depuis de nombreuses années maintenant
après je dirais dix ans de gestion
socialiste
on a vu l'augmentation du chômage qui a
été multiplié par deux sur la
circonscription notamment
et puis et bien on se rend compte quand
on se découvre un petit peu la
haute-saône notamment le centre ville de
lure le centre ville d'héricourt de
luxeuil que les commerçants
disparaissent ferme que les centristes
sont en train de mourir et aussi voilà
nous on est là aussi pour essayer de
défendre ccc magasins de proximité
quand un archos vous vous représentez
ici le parti communiste français vous
avez à côté de vous donc une autre
candidate de gauche il y en ad'autres
également dans une circonscription au
front national atteint des sommets est
ce que c'était vraiment nécessaire de
multiplier les candidatures à gauche et
pas moyen de s'entendre
la question c'est pas moi qu'il faut la
poser s'il faut la poser à mes camarades
de la france a soumises et les autres
qui sont responsables alors répondait
déjà pour vous puis après on fera
répondre votre collègue de de droite
pour ma part et pour
le parti communiste on a quand même fait
le rassemblement pour les
présidentielles autour de la candidature
de jean luc mélenchon
donc on n'a pas de leçon à recevoir en
termes d'unités et sur sur la haute
saône pour ma candidature j'ai tenté à
plusieurs reprises de rencontrer dès
novembre la france a soumises qui a
finalement décidé de fermer la porte à
ma candidature
donc là on va la laisser répondre
pourquoi c'était pas possible de vous
entendre avec le parti communiste
français alors que vous êtes censé avoir
fait une campagne commune pour la
présidentielle et alors que dans cette
circonscription
le front national est très très très
fort il une consultation nationale du
parti communiste est en fait en haute
saône il ya seulement qu il ya 83 % des
personnes deux des militants un pc qui
n'ont pas voulu soutenir la candidature
de jean luc mélenchon pas de ma faute
c'est la faute des autres
non c'est à dire que du coup ça des
choses sont claires et puis un jeu quand
un tu dis que des propositions ont été
faites moi j'en ai jamais reçu aucune et
je rêvais le j'aurais personnellement
non urgents moi j'en ai jamais
personnellement mais les rencontres avec
france insoumise avec monsieur bernard
morel elles ont eu lieu
je ne peux pas les eaux là je pense que
dans le couloir il va y avoir une
explication de gravure en cela ce tir
que c'est les circonscriptions
bon allez au patrick adam pour debout la
france
on a vu donc votre patron de parti
debout la france nicolas dupont aignan
s'associer avec marine le pen pour
l'élection présidentielle il y aura
apporté son soutien pour le deuxième
tour vous
vous sentez comment vous par rapport à
tout ça vous appuyer cette décision et
si oui parce que vous m'avez dit oui
pourquoi vous présentez alors qu'un
candidat du front national
à quoi ça sert que vous présentiez je
dirais pour reprendre métaphore médicale
entre la peste et la grippe je préfère
la grippe entre le programme aliénant et
déshumanisant alors qu'elle est la peste
qui est la grippe à votre avis donc le
nord soyez clair n'annonce rien du front
national on a eu des discussions butent
et la grippe eux c'est la grée là on a
pu faire un programme une plate-forme
commune pour les présidentielles
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup d'amendements
de leur programme émanant de dupont
aignan tandis qu'avec la république en
marche là à part le vide insondable de
leur programme
la solide et fort ce qui émerge sait
faire front au front national feront au
front national faire face au front
national qu'ils ont eux mêmes créé
qu'ils ont eux mêmes créés parce que je
suis revenu dans la région après 26 ans
en qualité de médecin habilité ou j'ai
parcouru la france et le monde
j'ai trouvé une situation catastrophique
tant dans le délitement des services
publics
la paupérisation du monde rural la
désindustrialisation massive de nos
villes et tout ça je veux ce que je
souhaite c'est que chacun assume les
responsabilités de ce qui s'est passé
alors après ce premier tour de table je
vous demande et jean-françois de laisser
la place à nicolas basse tuque de l'est
républicain donc sur cette 2e
circonscription de haute saône donc la
haute saône à l'ouest donc le score du
front national est très très élevé c'est
le plus élevé de l'ensemble des
circonscriptions de franche comté et
vous nicolas vous avez décidé
d'interroger ces candidats justement sur
le front national oui cela a été dit
bonjour à tous d'avoir cela a été dit au
cours de cette émission le front
national a battu tous les records la
présidentielle dans cette
circonscription 33% au premier tour pour
marine le pen auquel il faut ajouter
peut-être les 16,6 pour cent de jean luc
mélenchon donc sans nier la part
d'adhésion que ces votes peuvent
renfermer
il est certain qu'il y a une part
importante de protestation ou de
désespoir dans ce vote puisque on peut
considérer qu'un électeur sur deux a
voté pour un parti
or system pour un parti contestataire
alors la question que je voulais vous
poser
premièrement comment vous
key ces scores très importants et puis
surtout la deuxième c'était fort
national écoutant est ce que c'est le
sentiment d'abandon décrit par tous les
politiques politologues dans les dents
les dans la ruralité
dans l'est la périphérie deuxièmement
quelle mesure vous entendez prendre pour
vider un peu cette cette anxiété qui
semble saisir les électeurs de la 2e
circonscription
on va commencer par vous peut-être
madame allez-y donc en fait se regarde
bien la carte des inégalités ce des
inégalités en france on pourrait
l'appliquer sur la carte du vote fn
donc c'est vraiment ça c'est un taux de
chômage massif des scolarisation
d'élèves donc son diplôme pauvreté
familles monoparentales des bassins
d'emploi on voit la désindustrialisation
concurrence délocalisations service de
proximité qui s'éloigne de plus en plus
patient de dans des petites villes mais
de moins en moins de commerces dans les
petits villages c'est les petits
villages meurt en fait on essaie
vraiment l'isolément des personnes
on va faire circuler la parole oui
monsieur
donc moi j'ai une phrase un peu pour
résumer tout ça et qu'ils s'aiment
l'incompétence récolte la désespérance
des tonnes d'efforts mais là comment
vous êtes l'homme des formules que de ça
je mets également une action mes propos
si vous voulez moi je rencontre vous
proposez quoi concrètement je rends
compte la souffrance au quotidien
ce que je propose c'est un
bouleversement radical de tout système
vous avez évoqué les problèmes à l'école
moi je rencontre tous les jours des
élèves qui sont déscolarisés qui ont des
difficultés à trouver un emploi les
formations qui aboutissent à des
impasses les personnes âgées qui voient
leur niveau de vie baisser
considérablement
il faut savoir que l'heure actuelle 37 %
des retraités sont un euro près pour
gérer leur budget pas si vous voyez
plutôt à plus d'un tiers des personnes
donc ce que je propose c'est tout à la
fois au niveau de l'éducation remettre
de l'autorité redonner de l'espoir aux
gens et l'espoir vous l'avez en libérant
le système en permettant aux
entrepreneurs d'entreprendre sans qu'y
être démarche ministre vous vous
permettez qu'on fasse circuler un petit
peu la parole
monsieur have caused pour le parti
communiste s'il vous plaît vous quelles
sont concrètement les mesures que vous
voulez proposer alors je vais aussi
faire une petite citation c'est la
déclaration d'un représentant du front
national en janvier 2010 est devant le
medef
donc je le cite je rappelle que nous
sommes de vrais libéraux partisans
semblent ambiguïté de l'économie de
marché et de la libre entreprise le
front national surfer sur la peur mais
c'est tout ce qu'il fait sur le plan
économique c'est exactement la même
chose que ce qui a été fait depuis dix
ans ce sont ni plus ni moins qu des
gardes-chiourmes du capital est temps
que les électeurs n'auront pas compris
cela
les choses ne pourront pas avancer ça ne
peut se faire que sur une candidature
communiste clairement pour les
travailleurs gare de chemin du capital
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre à ça
j'écoute et voilà la situation je les
dis on tournait est préoccupante
il ya de la pauvreté il ya la précarité
ça c'est inquiétant
le problème c'est que vous vous ne
proposez rien non plus vous êtes là un
petit peu que proposez vous concrètement
il faut soutenir nos commerçants de
proximité
il faut soutenir les services publics de
proximité les maisons médicales de santé
également il faut redynamiser la
ruralité parce que c'est ça le problème
c'est la ruralité qui est délaissé ces
laissés pour contre deux des politiques
actuelles en place oui madame un oui il
ya une vraie fracture entre le monde
rural et le monde urbain
une des solutions ça va être comme dans
le programme c'est un euro investi pour
la rural pour les zones urbaines c'est
un euro investi pour les zones rurales
ça ça me paraît indispensable c'est ça
qui va permettre effectivement de
d'avoir des services de proximité
d'avoir des maisons médicales d'avoir
des commerces qui sont
un peu plus attrayant et voilà c'est ça
me semble indispensable pour réduire
cette fracture entre le monde rural et
le monde urbain qui permet de
cristalliser justement c'est votre côté
stats elles il y a aussi aussi des
choses très positives qui se passe dans
cette circonscription la chapelle de
ronchamp qui a été classé au patrimoine
mondial des agriculteurs qui prennent
des initiatives
il faut qu'on fasse réagir monsieur le
jeune est ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu
trop anxiogène vous les politiques est
ce que vous ne devriez pas exalté un
petit peu ce qui ce qui se fait bien
simplement je vais rappeler mon histoire
personnelle je suis maire de beaucourt
ses 550 de l'habitant cette commune
réalise régulièrement au niveau national
un score pour le front national c'est à
dire c'est à dire que plus de 50% des
habitants de la commune ont voté front
national vous n'avez pas démissionner
quand tu n'es pas démissionner il qu ils
connaissent ma position et ils m'ont
réélu vous sentez responsable quelque
part ou pas ils m'ont réélu à 80 7%
donc au quotidien il s'agit bien d'une
action locale d'une élection locale
ils reconnaissent mon investissement les
solutions je leur ai apporté
parce que là j'entends des constats
est-ce que vous en tant que maire d'une
commune qui votent à plus de 50% front
national est ce que vous vous sentez
responsable de ce vote front national
qu'est ce que vous comprenez je le
comprends mais eux me disent aussi ne
t'inquiète pas il y à l'élection
nationale c'est une chose là pour les
législatives il s'agit d'une élection
locale
c'est une si tu nous lis c'est un
rapport le député de la nation monsieur
c'est un rapport entre le terrain local
et l'assemblée nationale
il y a un lien il y a un lien très très
fort sur le conçois sur le concède il
faut faire du local et du national
aujourd'hui
de quoi ont besoin nous administrer ces
d'un maillage fort la ruralité c'est une
réalité mais il faut rassembler les
moyens les moyens ils ne sont pas que
financier ils sont humains on a parlé
des problèmes mais il ya aussi des
entreprises avec des dirigeants très
compétent qui souhaite avancer le très
haut débit est une nécessité
le maillage routier l'a19 l'a57 terminer
en deux fois deux voies sont une
nécessité
et derrière il y aura de l'emploi il ya
la création de richesses et il ya de la
vie
et ça c'est une nécessité une question
peut-être candidat du front national et
c est ce que juste pour la route dans
l'intérêt du pays et n'auriez-vous pas
intérêt à mettre en avant ce qui se fait
de bien ce qui se construit
plutôt que de surfer en permanence sur
l'anxiété sur le sentiment d'abandon
qu'il peut être et on a un psychiatre
ici qui est peut-être plus dans les
têtes que dans les feuilles
préoccupations les l'un c'est que les
français sont là mais de discours
positive et oui mais si si les
politiques faisait correctement leur
travail peut-être qu'on pourrait
possible positive et le problème c'est
qu'ils défendent d'abord leurs intérêts
je vais prendre l'exemple du conseil
régional où madame du fait première
mesure a augmenté de 20 % les indemnités
des élus
deuxième mesure elle est venue pour
taxer les cartes grises voilà voilà la
réalité c'est que les politiques une
fois en place eh bien ils pensent déjà
eu avant de penser aux concitoyens
vous parliez de ronchamp de 20 secondes
à la dent vous parliez de ronchamp est
descendu dans la ville de ronchin
etes-vous descendu dans les villes
forcément briller donc on a le sentiment
qu'on est juste après 1945 un lot là on
va pas partir sur ce terrain là je vous
interromps parce qu'on n'a pas le maire
de ronchamp et le conseil municipal
donc merci nicolas d'avoir participé à
cette émission on va faire revenir jean
françois fernandez donc beau pour la
dernière partie de cette émission il
reste un peu plus de neuf minutes
jean françois fernandez vous souhaitiez
revenir sur quelques points avec avec
nos invités où commencer par un madame
j'ai un staff est alors j'ai noté une
proposition intéressante parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de constats et très peu de
propositions finalement vous dites à un
moment la solution ses pour un euro
investi en zone urbaine investir un euro
aussi en zone rurale quels mécanismes on
peut on peut faire il faut une loi
comment faire pour concrétiser cette
proposition oui il va falloir légiférer
tout à fait pour arriver à équilibrer
ces territoires parce que moi ce que je
veux c'est qu'il y ait un rééquilibre
des territoires on le voit au quotidien
et
et est il est indispensable maintenant
que ces territoires ruraux ne sent plus
isolé et qu'on est vraiment une vraie
dynamique en direction des entreprises
d'épaisseur il le dit on le dit sans
arrêt comment concrètement vous donner
les moyens pour arriver à cet objectif
et côté il ya des ya des crédits qui
sont alloués à la politique de la ville
par exemple et bien un moment donné il
va falloir rééquilibrer tout cela c'est
également je pense à quelque chose qui
va être mis en oeuvre c'est les classes
dédoublées pour les cp des classes
dédoublées c'est une proposition de la
république en marge des classes
dédoublées pour des élèves en en zone
prioritaire
et ben moi je considère qu' on va faire
répondre aux zones rurales honda aussi
des dialogues et et pourquoi est ce
qu'en zone urbaine
on aurait des classes de 12 élèves et
que en zone rurale on continue à 3
monsieur la jeune voilà très très
concrètement c'est une proposition du
président de la république à la rentrée
prochaine dans les zep les zones
d'éducation prioritaire les cp 12
classes maximum la campagne devrait s'y
mettre aussi ou pas alors au niveau des
classes de niveaux en campagne avoir
plus de 12 élèves
quand vous prenez des communes de 6 700
habitants avoir vingt élèves pour une
classe de niveau c'est régulièrement le
cas des classes ou liées à une trentaine
d'élèves en milieu rural il faut nous
expliquer où elles sont en haute saône
ensuite pour si c'est une chose mais où
madame ensuite la table la réalité du
terrain les les zones prioritaires
c'est là où il ya une problématique
entre autres d'intégration
d'assimilation avec les parents qui sont
issus très souvent de l'immigration et
donner les moyens aux enfants de
s'intégrer parce que c'est une des
problématiques de notre pays c'est
l'intégration avant toute chose et vous
comprenez que les autres parents se
sentent un petit peu délaissé ce sens
que commencer est ce qu'il ya des zep
allure à héricourt à luxeuil
il y en a des zep ou par des que pas à
luxeuil pas inclure à héricourt oui
saint louis par contre une chose qui est
certaine qu'elle veut de circonscription
n'est pas complètement oublié quand même
bien s'il ya g
alors on va reprendre une doublette
classe compte vraiment c'est très minime
eh bien on suivra ce dossier là
l'équilibré territorial oui
jean-françois une question pour maurice
monnier je sais bien entendu dire que
vous voulez soutenir le commerce de
proximité soutenir les services publics
je vais être un peu provocateur est-ce
que c'est pas être aller coûte entre
guillemets du rejet des électeurs sur le
bassin du rond avec tous qui ferment
entre guillemets pour être négatif
est-ce que vous avez des propositions
pour arriver justement à ce soutien
c'est quoi c'est le public bien sûr oui
et puis donc les euros en ville
politique de la ville vous seriez
d'accord pour voter ça bien sûr c'est
évident notamment la suppression du rsi
qui étouffe les indépendants ça c'est
déjà la priorité voilà c'est pas
forcément la campagne et récits y en a
où il ya et des récits aussi en ville
mais bien sûr mais je vous expliquais
que les commerces ferment dans les
villes petit à petit on se retrouve avec
dd sur notre circonscription une
désertification des commerces de
proximité des services publics c'est dû
notamment pour les commerçants ces duos
et récits et ses dieux ou charge
également les communes ont un rôle à
jouer que les 6,5 qui pose les questions
des candidats ou madame et ce même si
elle veut prendre la parole on lui donne
vous êtes d'accord
oui déciderez si vous répondez ou pas ma
dernière semaine je vais aller se mettre
aux commerçants ruraux 2
devient pire leurs carnets de commandes
donc c'est bien quand tant de pouvoir
leur trouver des communaux de leur
envoyer des commandes d'auxi de passer
des commandes
moi ça m'a drôlement surpris de voir que
votre trek personnel personnel enfin le
local avait été imprimée aux presses de
france dans le 16e arrondissement de
paris
bon pourquoi ça paye t vous savez qu'on
a des imprimeurs à bâtir voilà une
question précise alors répondez vous à
bien on a un kit de campagne qui est
gérée par le siège
moi j'ai fait des tracts locaux que je
distribue et qui ont été imprimés en
haute saône
voilà tout simplement le temps de la
conclusion est arrivé vous allez
commencer madame esman je vais vous avez
40 secondes pour conclure ce débat mais
je vais essayer de trouver des solutions
puisqu'on apparaît allez donc on voit
bien que les politiques qu'on a eu
depuis plus de trente ans elles ont pas
de solution donc c'est pour ça qu'on
veut autre chose
est ce qu'il faut c'est déjà changer les
institutions ici à la tête de la france
il nous faut des personnes qu'ils ne
soient plus ou d'une soumise aux lois de
la finance et après on répartit les
richesses ont réparti et là on réinjecte
sur les territoires on a des aides on
est une banque on supporter je clique on
peut y arriver on a vraiment les moyens
de faire crever nos territoires est que
tout le monde puisse vivre dignement
monsieur adam pour debout la france
alors pour debout la france nous on est
également pour le renouvellement alors
ce renouvellement ne se fera pas avec
les défroquées du socialisme qui ont qui
ont plongé ce territoire dans la
déshérence nous au niveau des solutions
concrètes parce qu'on a un territoire
qui est très riche d'une diversité des
territoires dans la haute-saône la 2e
circonscription
nous on est massivement pour une aide
aux agriculteurs avec l'établissement de
pics de prix plancher pour leurs denrées
remettre un maillage industriel utilisé
les services publics et non pas créer
des coquilles vides pas créer des
maisons de santé qu'on ne pourra pas
remplir mes analyses et au plus près du
terrain
les besoins et hier pour va laisser la
parole à à qantas cost pour le parti
communiste français
oui ben ma candidature c'est la seule à
pouvoir rassembler à gauche parce que
c'est la seule qui n'a jamais renoncé à
ses valeurs
moi mes convictions j'ai pas attendu 1
ouvert suprême pour les avoir chevillée
au corps et pour porter un projet donc
j'appelle toutes les personnes de gauche
à se rassembler derrière ma candidature
et on demandait des propositions
concrètes
les gens s'ils veulent un meilleur
lendemain il ya une solution très simple
augmenter les salaires
1400 euros nets dès le début de mon
mandat
merci beaucoup mais si vous gagnez votre
conclusion si vous pourquoi qu'il faut
un véritable renouveau politique sur sur
la haute saône et sur l'ensemble des
territoires oubliés de cette république
notamment les territoires ruraux qui
souffrent de cette désertification
médicale qui souffrent de sept de ses
services publics qu'ils ferment nos
agriculteurs je rappelle qu'il ya un
agriculteur tous les deux jours qui se
suicide
donc voilà le las et c'est très
préoccupant et stuff le jeune vous avez
aussi 30 secondes vrai dire ou à peine
plus pour conclure ce débat
à l'image de ce nouveau gouvernement au
delà des clivages anciens et partisan je
rassemble les talents les forces les
énergies des hommes et des femmes de la
2e circonscription de haute saône
je suis le candidat de la majorité
présidentielle des manuels macron très
bien merci beaucoup
madame gm pour donc les républicains
votre conclusion
moi je peux comprendre les votes
contestataires les partis contestataires
savons la vue là tout à l'heure ça va
mieux dénoncer des problèmes qu'on
apportait des réponses applicables je
comprends aussi le vote pour le parti
république en marche qu'il a pour le
nouveau président de la république
puisque ça a l'air d'être un renouveau
or le gouvernement actuel faut pas s'y
tromper est construit sur des ambiguïtés
des reniements des contradictions et des
intérêts personnels
et ça ça peut éclater à n'importe quel
moment
on voit aussi les problèmes votre temps
est terminée alors dit non je voudrais
simplement terminal et les secondes à
bêta centre ont un problème ont un
programme
réalise réalistes et réalisables avec
moi 10 % des impôts avec juste je vais
juste donner pour terminer la liste des
autres candidats en lice dans cette
circonscription de christophe devillers
du parti de la france
mario gaza alliance écologiste
indépendante fatigue est parti égalité
justice comme marc onno sans étiquette
hélène petit jean hubert il faut
dissiper la daniel rouillon de lutte
ouvrière et marie claire thomas d'europe
écologie les verts
donc on se retrouve vous pouvez bien sûr
suivre revoir ses débats sur notre site
internet et on se retrouve sur notre
site internet
à 15 heures pour deux autres
circonscriptions la deuxième du
territoire de belfort et celle là 5ème
du doubs merci beaucoup merci mesdames
messieurs au revoir et bon dimanche à
tous
à tout à l'heure vous restez en place
s'il vous plaît